genève bruxelles puis viennent tel était
le programme de cette semaine marathon
pour la diplomatie russe afin d'évoquer
les garanties de sécurité demandées par
moscou tout a donc commencé sur les
rives du lac léman avec la rencontre
entre la secrétaire d'état adjointe des
états unis et le vice ministre russe des
affaires étrangères l'occasion pour ce
dernier de réitérer les demandes de
moscou
l'ukraine et la géorgie ne deviendront
jamais jamais membre de l'otan ce serait
un changement bienvenu pour le meilleur
dans la position de l'otan nous en avons
assez des paroles en l'air des demies
promesse d interprétation erronée de ce
qui s'est passé lors des différentes
formes de négociations à huis clos
réponse la partie américaine a évoqué le
soutien des états unis aux principes
internationaux de souveraineté
d'intégrité territoriale et à la liberté
des pays de choisir leur propre alliance
malgré tout le premier sentiment est
plutôt positif côté russe et sergueï
riabkov a eu l'impression d'être entendu
[Musique]
la conversation a été complexe longue
très professionnelle approfondie
concrètes sans aucune tentative
d'embellir quoique ce soit de contourner
les angles vifs nous avons eu
l'impression que la partie américaine a
pris les propositions russes très au
sérieux
insidious d'un choix
deux jours plus tard sommet russie otan
sous haute tension à bruxelles le
secrétaire général de l'alliance
atlantique a de nouveau exprimé ses
inquiétudes concernant la présence
militaire russe près de la frontière
ukrainienne et même si l'otan reste
ferme sur de nombreux points comme sa
politique de portes ouvertes certaines
concessions pourraient faire l'objet de
discussions
les alliés souhaitent discuter des
moyens concrets d'accroître la
transparence des exercices militaires
de prévenir les incidents militaires
dangereux et de réduire les menaces
spatial et cybernétique
les alliés ont également proposé d'
examiner la maîtrise des armements le
désarmement et la non prolifération
ainsi que d'aborder les limitations
réciproque en matière de missiles et les
politique nucléaire
de son côté le représentant russe a
tenté d'expliquer que la sécurité du
continent européen devait être penser
globalement en incluant la russie
nous sommes fermement convaincus que le
principe d'un visibilité de la sécurité
doit prendre en compte les intérêts de
tous que les tentatives de construire la
sécurité contre la russie sans
participation de la russie sous
contre-productive et vouée à l'échec
nous n'admettrons pas cela si l'otan se
lance dans une politique de dissuasion
alors ce sera une politique de contre
dissuasion de notre part alors nous y
opposerons de la contrainte imitation
[Musique]
la réunion de l'osce à vienne est
ensuite venu clore ce ballet
diplomatique
il y a été souligné l'importance du
dialogue alors que le risque d' escalade
militaire n'a jamais été aussi élevé
les idées rue sur lesquels nous avons
débattu à genève à bruxelles et l'ici à
vienne sur la plateforme de l'ouest se
représente en fait un moment de vérité
qui devrait déterminer si nous pouvons
nous mettre d'accord sur les lignes à ne
pas franchir sur les principes
inviolables qui ne peuvent être
outrepassées
comme l'a formulé sergueï lavrov moscou
attend désormais une réponse écrite à
ces demandes de la part de ses
partenaires occidentaux
une réponse qui conditionnera la
réaction de la russie en conclusion les
domaines désormais apparemment ouvert à
la négociation comprennent des
limitations réciproque du déploiement de
systèmes de missiles une réduction de
l'ampleur des manoeuvres militaires et
la réouverture des voies de
communication militaire de son côté
l'otan ne compte pas renoncer à sa
politique de la porte ouverte l'alliance
atlantique ne retirera pas non plus ses
troupes et ses infrastructures
stationnés dans les anciens pays du
pacte de varsovie qui ont adhéré après
1997 comme moscou l'a demandé en
attendant la situation sur le terrain
reste extrêmement tendue
et imprévisible dernier exemple en date
avec cette accusation américaine qui
prétend que moscou serait en train de
créer de toutes pièces un prétexte pour
une invasion de l'est ukrainien une
accusation rejetée par le kremlin même
si le dialogue a le mérite d'exister les
progrès restent pour l'instant minimes
et la situation sur le terrain à
couteaux tirés